leute ich möchte einfach dass ihr wenn
ihr diese person irgendwo findet auch
wenn sie nicht vorzeitig gemacht hat
sollte einfach nicht gemeint
die welt macht mich noch schlechter
werden heute
ich höre von wirklich viel aushalten und
ich glaub ich hab auch wirklich ein
dickes fell mit der zeit gewonnen am
anfang nicht mehr echt vieles
nahegegangen über die ganzen kommentare
die männer bekommen du [ __ ] verfügt
dich du wirst du hoch geprüften würdest
das hat mich damals schon richtig
getroffen als ich angefangen habe
mittlerweile trifft mich das nicht mehr
so wer also man lernt ihr wieder mit
umzugehen entwickelt irgendeiner art und
weise mit den kommentaren klarzukommen
man baut irgendwie wieder als
schutzschild aufgezeichnet wird
eigentlich auch ganz gut funktionieren
also zweier kommentaren gibt vielleicht
maximal einen der einen wirklich für das
sind vor allem die kommentare wo leute
wirklich sich zeit genommen hast video
eingehen konstruktiv kritisieren die
punkt retten wo man sich schon gedacht
okay faktor muss wirklich was man macht
ihr kennt ja selbst youtube souverän auf
kommentare reagieren wollen der
wärmeverlust sich das in tief beleidigt
werden und auch wir selbst beleidigt
fühlen versuchen in berlin zu tun
manchmal werden sie hat wirklich
getroffen und gibt so manche dinge die
bleiben mit einem auch immer die kamera
ausmacht auch wenn man ein video fertig
geschnitten hat den computer runterfährt
das bleibt einfach bei einem versteht
ihr das wirklich weiß was einfach an
einem hängen bleibt was ein verfolgt man
kann nachts nicht mehr schlafen wetten
weiter becker leute und sein die alles
gut war ein sonniger tag werden über
blau alle versuche glaubt dahin läuft er
wieder zum bäcker weg und sie bestehen
aus einem schaufenster in diesem eine
spiegelung in diesem schaufenster
[Musik]
er hat genau das gemacht was in diesem
kommentar deutschland die person hatte
wirklich recht davon so die dinge die
einen wirklichen aber normalerweise kann
ich damit umgehen aber heute habe ich
das gefühl auf twitter deshalb einfach
für den rest gegeben wieder mitarbeiter
dem wie damals ein leben danach noch
weiter für wie meister vorgekühlt wenn
ein dort trifft man erreicht es wird ein
doch vollkommen aus der bahn also erst
mal ich muss natürlich sagen das wird
wirklich mega knalliges dieses video von
dieser personen aber die botschaft ist
halt einfach nicht so gründlich dass es
möglich oder man leute müssen wirklich
ein bisschen dinge wird es mir viele
gedanken mache ihr wisst ja ich habe in
meiner schule damals auch probleme
versetzt zu werden von den sitzen in die
abfahrt werden von der achten und
neunten klasse sagt ich hab mir immer
gedanken darüber gemacht bist du als 1
intelligent oder nicht bist du
intelligent oder bist du den ich schon
die ganzen tag über tief im inneren
lässt einfach ich bin mir absolut voll
unsicherheit es wirklich um die halt die
farbe und da kommt so was wie sagt man
erforderlichen bilder mann genommen
heute kennt ihr das wenn ihr euch um
euer selbstbild aufgebaut habe
ein kartenhaus zusammenfällt
ich bin noch keine bilder mann oder ich
weiß noch gar nicht was ihr von behaltet
ihr auch spinnen bilder mann oder hab
ich mir die ganze zeit nur nur gedacht
hat nämlich für für schlauer als stoff
für intelligent oder für unterhaltsame
und wirklichkeit auch gedacht sich im
bilde man bin ich brauche leute ich weiß
nicht ob ich jetzt so weiter youtube
machen kann
eleganter gewesen sei dann bei uns nicht
drauf gekommen ach ja auch super hier
von dem von der selben person noch eine
anlage sondern anlage müsste was du bist
mein selbstwertgefühl ist auf dem
tiefpunkt angekommen ich ländern am
boden kommt einfach noch jemanden treten
noch mal oben drauf ja nicht nur dass
ich blöd bin ich bin dann auch eine
blöde frau lass mir doch wenig schlecht
dass wieder weg für manchen sein wenn
ich schon bilder bei
ich bin ne blöde frau und beschützerin
und wieder zeigt bleibt es richtig nach
dem motto lass ich musste die ganze zeit
schauen
ich hab mir dabei zu gefährlich war war
jede video der reingewinn liegt mit
einer reichweite aufgebaut hat und gibt
dabei zugesehen wie du dachtest du als
erfolg du wirst wenn du irgendwas
aufgebaut und wenn du dir genau was
denkt ein höhepunkt angekommen
dann komme ich und machen die aber durch
nicht fertig diese lager wende ist
einfach
also leute scheinbar bin ich nicht nur
blöde war und andere schiffe dann ja
leute ich finde es einfach so witzig und
bittet für eingefallen ich hoffe niemand
dieses video missverstanden
selbstverständlich alles nur ein genre
konnten ist es gar nicht nötig ebenso
vor ort wie witzig ist das alter muss
ich natürlich wieder drüber machen sagt
wir auf jeden fall findet irgendwo der
kannst hab in meinem herzen da oder hat
ihr mann liegen kommentar oder so weiter
4 verlief sie hat mich natürlich nicht
ernst gemeint gewisse selbstverständlich
ich habe mich damit ihr geschrieben wird
gesagt dass wir verwenden mehr leute
wenn ihr ein bisschen moralisch
unterstützen wollt könnt ihr hier oben
ein kanal abonnieren und hier unten
altes video von mir sehen nicht hören
lassen wird auch nach oben da und eine
zeitung